They're our Klout scores. So first let's calculate the mean. Push Cmd down arrow
key and then you see that there are 1,048 values. And make sure we don't have a
header row, which we don't. So we know that n is 1,048. So anywhere really, we
can write equals, average, A1, colon A1048. So we get that the mean is 37.72
approximately. Let's calculate the standard deviation. We calculated our mean in
cell D1048. Cell rate in cell B1, equals A1 minus $D $1048, which keeps the
value in cell D1048 constant. Okay, the we'll go to cell B1 hit Cmd+C to copy
it, go to cell A1, Cmd down arrow key go to cell B1048, Cmd+Shift up arrow key.
So all of column B is highlighted, Cmd+B. Now we have all our deviations. And
actually what we could do is instead, we can just calculate the square
deviations. So let's put parenthesis around the deviation and then square it.
Now let's copy this and paste it. Now we have all our squared deviations in
column B. So we calculate the variance by taking the average of this, equals
average B1:B1048. So that's our variance and then our standard deviation is the
square root, equals square root of D1.